the Red Cross Red Crescent climate
Center our job is to help others
understand and address what's going on
with climate change and with extreme
events hurricanes typhoons too much
rainfall peak temperatures and these
things are complicated the science is
complex and how to turn science into
action is not easy if you're too busy to
learn most of our colleagues in the
humanitarian sector are insanely busy
when science is communicated it is very
often either incomprehensible or
difficult to link to ongoing
humanitarian processes so about six
seven years ago we started creating
playful activities where participants in
a workshop have to make decisions that
have consequences and that's at the core
of games games are systems where you
have to make a decision with limited
information you're trying to accomplish
something and you don't really know what
may happen because there's something in
the system that you don't control which
can be the weather can be what other
people do can be just you're not fully
understanding the system in our
experience as humanitarian workers
trying to infuse awareness of complexity
into our work games are the most
wonderful tool to whet the appetite to
make people want to learn more and want
to do better
it has been beautiful to work with the
MIT game lab we have as Red Cross family
access to a lot of talent a lot of
enthusiastic brainpower that combines
analytical competence with creative
juices that is prevalent in the field of
game design and among students of games
what we find that MIT is that it's much
easier to link to other departments that
are directly connected to what we do can
be about environmental engineering can
be about climate science can be about
technology development so this
partnership is the beginning of
something that is inevitably going to
grow to grow beautiful to grow build it
was also really nice to see how the MIT
game lab is well connected to other
partners that we have in the game design
sector such as the engagement lab at
Emerson or the pet lab team at Parsons
and the awareness of reach in the word
of serious games games that are in
telling not just as a playful activity
but with an intention to improve the
world somehow
we could always do better as partners of
the academic team if we could allocate
more time unfortunately it is in the
very nature of our Red Cross work that
we have to travel insanely I was out of
the country for at least half of the
time when the course happened so we did
bring in partners and friends who gave a
hand but I think one of the key
challenges for this kind of partnership
between game-related academia and
humanitarian teams is to find ways to
interact more frequently more deeply to
learn about each other we just don't
know how we can do more with the limited
time we have
when students engage with partners
clients from the real world it is not
easy for them to get into the shoes of
the institution of the organization that
has to try to accomplish things so one
of the most important things that we
could offer as partners in this course
was to give a flavor of the context in
which the game would be played so we
have a team working on color of
prevention in West Africa and they
developed a video game that had the
flavor of modern wealthy homes and you
know in West Africa most of our target
audience if you're trying to prevent
color our chances are they're poor and
the aesthetics need to resonate it can
be about a super stellar context or it
can be about a thatched roof but it
should be something that can evoke
engagement on the part of the player and
that's not easy for students to find out
they actually have to do research on
what does a home in West Africa look
like the other thing we can do is to
help narrow down and focus on what
matters to us in terms of the game
informing better decisions and to win a
way to filter out all the things that
students want to include because they
can but that's not a good enough reason
just the fact that it's technically
feasible or that you like it doesn't
mean that it should make it into a final
prototype there were many other things
that were a lot of fun in terms of
engaging with students that I think were
useful to them in particular to see how
they could get inspired by being aware
of how their technical competence can be
useful for development work for
humanitarian work for actually
physically saving lives in the long term
or to help people engage with each other
in other continents in other contexts in
fields that they don't even know but
they can help
when an academic team is offering
student brain power and air time during
a course for an organization
specifically in games but also more
broadly it is our experience that it
takes more time than we think to develop
the relationship and to understand how
we can really get juice out of it it is
always worth starting if the client
organization if the partner like in our
case the Red Cross family can find
someone who spends a little bit of time
at the beginning a little of time
reviewing prototypes and some feedback
along the way it's definitely worth it
but don't expect magic solutions don't
expect people to be able to read your
mind we come from different universities
and we have an opportunity to bring the
real word to academia by just showing up
and spending time but also to bring
academic brainpower talent and
creativity into our work one of the
things that I have to say with enormous
pride is that one of the prototypes that
emerged from one of the groups in this
course was actually used in three global
events and helped hundreds of people in
real time learn what was being thought
about people entered three words as
individuals there were a Henry or more
people in the room and everyone saw a
word cloud that emerged through very fun
gameplay and this can really help but we
need to be aware of the time it takes to
mature we have been working with game
designers for at least six years and
that really helped us channel our energy
in a more narrowly defined way otherwise
it's very easy to go abroad and to be
disappointed be prepared to acknowledge
your own limitations but be prepared to
explore the space of possibility
so the game snap is already ready to
deploy has been deployed I hope we can
refine the user interface to give more
choices to facilitator and so on but
that is one game that I predict we'll be
able to change the way real word events
happen I have that ambition I think we
can do something with it of the many
other games that were good because they
were more about a subject matter that is
outside of Cambridge Massachusetts they
will take more time to refine I'm very
excited about the cholera game which we
now have a partnership with UNICEF and
we anticipate the demand from UNICEF
Ghana in particular to try to add
digital flavors to their relationship to
school children in prevention of
anything in promotion of the things that
held like hand-washing with soap which
we take for granted here but in other
parts of the word they just have to
choose between soap and food it's hard
to make that case some of the other game
prototypes have very insightful game
mechanics how to display territory in a
small screen how to display quantities
for decisions in terms of disaster
preparedness the representation on a
game on heat wave of how people can just
collapse if they think they can just go
out and work on an excessively sunny hot
day these are things that are there are
latent and we have opportunities to work
deeper either with the students or with
future students of MIT and beyond they
will need more time to refine and we
have as Red Cross more work to do in
terms of identifying the potential user
and identifying the potential player I
mean and identifying what are the
decisions that can be improved or what
are the discussions that can be enriched
by engaging in this game experience
from the Red Cross Red Crescent climate
Center and from the humanitarian family
I here by Thank profusely the MIT game
lab and by extension game designers that
have helped us become partners with you
now for setting up a space where we can
learn how magically powerful but
analytically clear gameplay can be to
help accomplish humanitarian goals thank
you so much